-A bizarre, and, ultimately,
pointless, drama
unfolded yesterday
after Piers Morgan,
an on-and-off friend and ally
of Donald Trump,
debuted a trailer
for an interview
in which he claimed
Trump angrily walked out
and then Trump
later released audio
he claimed contradicted
the trailer
and showed that, in reality,
the ending was cordial.
Also, coup plotter Rudy Giuliani
was on "The Masked Singer."
[ Laughter ]
For more on this --
Wait, do we want more on this?
Alright, we do?
Alright.
[ Laughter ]
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ Whistling ]
Republican politics, these days,
is often so relentlessly stupid,
it generally feels like we're
being punished for something.
[ Laughter ]
It's like we got busted
watching an episode of "Maury"
and God said,
"Okay, you like that?
How about if everything is
an episode of 'Maury'
[ Laughter ]
from now on?
Do you like that?"
Every damn day, we have to deal
with something insane,
like stories
about congressional orgies
or senators writing
Disney erotica
or cable hosts
pitching testicle tanning,
[ Laughter ]
and it always seems to come
from the same cluster
of weirdos,
like Ted Cruz, Tucker Carlson,
Rudy Giuliani, Donald Trump,
Matt Gaetz, Madison Cawthorn,
and Marjorie Taylor Greene.
[ Laughter ]
Their names are all starting
to blend together now
in one soup of insanity.
Did you hear
what Muckerie Gaelor Cawthump
said now?
[ Laughter ]
Did someone flip a switch
or something
that unleashed
all these weirdos on us?
It's like that scene
in "Ghostbusters"
where the EPA guy
makes them open the vault
and all the ghosts
come flying out.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, I could've sworn
I saw the zombie cabdriver
on "The Masked Singer"
last night.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Yeah.
You saw that Rudy Giuliani,
the guy who waged a lengthy
and unhinged campaign
to overturn the 2020 election,
who tried to help Donald Trump
steal millions of votes,
helped orchestrate a scheme
to extort the country of Ukraine
to help Trump cheat
in the election,
had his home and office
raided by the FBI,
is currently
under federal investigation
for various allegations,
and called for a trial
by combat
on the day of the
January 6th insurrection,
was on Fox's "Masked Singer"
last night.
That's a terrible, terrible
thing to do to people on 4/20.
[ Stoner voice ]
Hey, man.
[ Laughter, ohs, and applause ]
Hey, man,
that weed you gave me,
I think it's laced
with something, man.
[ Laughter ]
I'm seeing some
[bleep]-up [bleep], man!
[ Laughter and applause ]
And, when he was unmasked,
everyone was shocked,
including, apparently,
Rudy himself.
[ Suspenseful music plays ]
-Oh, my goodness!
Former associate
attorney general,
former mayor of New York City.
-Is that Robert Duval?
-No, that's not Robert Duval.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Rudy Giuliani!
-No! way!
-Oh...my...
-Oh, my God!
[ Fireworks explode ]
-gosh.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, Mr. Giuliani,
with all of the controversy
that's surrounding you
right now,
I think it surprises us all
that you're here
on "The Masked Singer."
-Me too!
[ Laughter and applause ]
-I'm sure he was surprised.
There's a good chance
Rudy genuinely
did not know where he was
[ Laughter and applause ]
and was just as surprised
as everyone else
when they opened that box.
He was probably thrilled,
by the way.
[ As Giuliani ]
A singing competition?
I just assumed
I was going to jail.
[ Laughter ]
I bet you could trick
Rudy Giuliani
into climbing
into almost any container,
just by telling him
there's a trove
of shredded Trump ballots
in there or, I don't know,
a bottle of scotch
that wasn't completely empty.
[ Laughter ]
Honestly, the idea
that any TV show
would help rehabilitate a key
figure in an attempted coup
for entertainment purposes is
so disgusting and shocking.
The only reality show
I would've been okay
with Rudy being on is
"Love Is Blind"...
[ Laughter ]
just to see if he accidentally
ends up marrying
his cousin again.
[ Laughter ]
[ Static crackling ]
So, where are you from?
32 East Flatbush Road?
That's where my aunt
and uncle live!
We got so much in common.
[ Laughter ]
And I'm sorry.
Whenever we make that joke,
I'm supposed to clarify
that it was
his second cousin
he married, you know,
as in someone who you share
a great-grandparent with,
not the second time
he married his cousin.
[ Laughter ]
Although I could definitely
see Rudy doing that twice
by accident, too.
[ As Giuliani ]
Honey, I was just looking
at the marriage certificate.
You accidentally put Giuliani
on the line for maiden name.
Giuliani is your maiden name?!
Oh, Rudy, you done it again!
[ Laughter and applause ]
And, again, I should clarify,
you know,
all jokes aside here,
when he married
his second cousin,
which is a real thing he did,
her maiden name wasn't Giuliani.
I mean, this man was the mayor
of New York City.
How dare I treat him
like some sort of clown?
[ Laughter ]
Oh, well, alright.
I guess it's fair now.
[ Laughter ]
You know who probably panicked
when Rudy Giuliani appeared
as a Jack-in-the-Box?
This guy.
[ Laughter ]
"Yeah.
I'm going to lay low
for a while."
[ Laughter ]
And yet, somehow, that was not
the only incredibly stupid
thing to happen
in Republican politics yesterday
because one of Trump's
longtime friends and allies,
Piers Morgan,
released an overly
dramatic trailer
for a new interview with Trump,
where he claimed Trump angrily
stormed out of the interview
when pressed
about his election lies.
-Okay, Piers, I'm ready.
[ Suspenseful music plays ]
-I'll be completely straight
to your face.
-I think I'm a very honest man.
Much more honest
than you, actually.
-Really?!
-Yeah.
-It was a free
and fair election.
You lost.
-Only a fool would think that.
-You think I'm a fool?
-I do now, yeah.
-With respect --
-Excuse me.
-With respect,
you haven't produced
the hard evidence.
-Excuse me.
I don't think you're real.
[ Voices overlapping ]
Very dishonest.
Let's finish up the interview.
Turn the camera off.
♪♪
Very dishonest.
-I'm sorry,
but who edited that trailer,
Michael Bay?
[ Laughter ]
Was there hand-to-hand combat?
Is this from the next
Jason Bourne movie,
where, instead of advanced
fighting skills,
Jason Bourne wakes up
in a poorly tailored suit?
[ Laughter and oohs ]
By the way, Piers Morgan himself
also famously
stormed off the set
of his own TV show in the UK
when he was challenged
on something he said.
These guys constantly call
the left snowflakes
and "get triggered,"
and then they
immediately melt down
when confronted
by even the gentlest questioning
from a friendly source.
I mean, look at Trump's face.
He's literally melting down.
[ Laughter ]
That's what a Yankee candle
looks like,
if you leave it out in the sun.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I believe that one is called...
[ Laughter, ohs, and applause ]
It will never not shock me
that anyone in the country
looks at that guy and says,
"That's a face I can trust."
[ Laughter ]
That looks like a mask
you'd rip off
to reveal Rudy Giuliani
on "The Masked Singer."
[ Laughter and applause ]
But then a weird thing happened,
where Trump's team
released audio
claiming he didn't
angrily walk out.
NBC News reported that...
Genuine fights don't end
with "Thank you very much.
I really appreciate it."
You've never seen
a ten-minute fight sequence
in a movie with The Rock
and Vin Diesel
punching each other
on top of a train,
dodging bullets, laying flat
when they go through a tunnel,
popping up again,
doing a windmill kick
to the other guy's face that
sends him flying off the train,
leading the other guy to relax
and assume the fight's over,
only to realize it's not over
because his nemesis climbs back
up onto the train after having
clung to a door handle...
[ Laughter ]
...so they fight
for another 10 minutes,
until both of them wrestle
each other back and forth
and fall dramatically
off the train,
across the river,
and continue to punch in midair
as they plunge 100 feet
into the icy rapids,
tumbling towards a waterfall,
where they cling to a rock,
until they lose their grip,
and then they grab
onto a tree branch,
narrowly escaping death,
and then they turn
to each other and say,
"Hey, man,
that was a great fight.
Thanks so much."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Of course -- Of course...
[ Cheering ]
...if it was Vin Diesel,
he wouldn't say that.
He would say --
[ As Diesel ]
It's all about family.
[ Laughter and applause ]
That's today's
in-Vin-cible impression.
[ Engine vrooms ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
That's what he said
when he pitched it.
[ As Diesel ]
It's all about family.
They're like, "But also cars?"
[ Laughter ]
What are we talking about?
Oh, right.
And Trump's account
would make sense
because even the initial
description of the interview
had this odd anecdote --
[ Laughter ]
It's so funny
you can trick Trump
into sitting for an interview
if you just ask him about golf.
He's so easy to checkmate.
It's like how you
[ Laughter ]
trick a golden retriever
into running after a tennis ball
by pretending to throw it.
[ Laughter ]
In Trump's case,
he'd just spend hours walking
around the White House lawn,
looking for it.
[ As Trump ]
Where's this freaking
tennis ball?
I ran all the way here.
I ran to find the tenni--
If I don't get that tennis ball,
I'm not going to get that treat
and, let me tell you,
I want that Milk-Bone.
[ Laughter ]
We love Milk-Bone,
don't we, folks?
[ Laughter ]
It combines the flavor of milk
with beef, chicken.
[ Laughter ]
What we're seeing here is that,
to all these guys,
whether it's Piers Morgan
or "The Masked Singer,"
it's all just entertainment.
They don't care
about what's actually at stake,
which is our democracy,
and, deep down,
most Republicans know it.
They know the truth.
As we learned from a bombshell
New York Times report
this morning
that revealed
senior GOP leaders,
including Kevin McCarthy
and Mitch McConnell,
were ready to push Trump
out of office
in the days after the
January 6th insurrection,
before changing their tune
and deciding
to stick with him
for political expediency.
-This morning, we're learning
that the nation's
top two Republicans
had serious concerns
about former President Trump's
ability to lead
in the wake of the January 6th
attack on the U.S. Capitol.
The New York Times is reporting
that House Minority Leader
Kevin McCarthy
told other Republican leaders
that he was going to advise
President Trump to resign.
The Times is also reporting
that McCarthy
and Senate Minority Leader
Mitch McConnell looked
into the 25th Amendment
as an option
for removing Trump from office.
-McCarthy, specifically,
the reporting says
he wanted to push Trump
to resign,
that he said,
"I've had it with this guy."
-I feel like, in the wake
of a violent attack
on the Capitol,
you should be able to muster
something a little stronger
than "I've had it
with that guy."
[ Laughter ]
Even their strongest
denunciations of Trump
behind closed doors sounds like
your dad complaining to you
about the guy
who does his landscaping.
"I've had it with this guy.
He keeps using the wrong mulch
and all my petunias are dying.
Alright, here's your mom."
[ Laughter ]
But this has always
been the case.
Behind the scenes,
they all knew --
every single one of them --
how dangerous Trump was.
But they need him for the
show business of it all.
Trump's like their
unmanageable Broadway diva.
"Shirley stabbed the wardrobe
guy with a chopstick
and he's threatening to sue.
Plus, she's drunk as a skunk
and curtain's in 10 minutes,
but goddamn it,
that broad can sing."
[ Laughter ]
A good rule of thumb
with these guys is,
whenever you can't tell
if they're dumb or evil,
the answer is all of the above.
[ Laughter ]
Republicans calculated they
could use Trump
for sinister political purposes
and, once again,
that's what happened
because,
as The New York Times reports...
And McCarthy even flew
down to Mar-a-Lago
to kiss Trump's ring
and pose for that photo
where they look like
two personal injury attorneys
who want to know if you have
asbestos in your house.
"Do you have asbestos?
Well, so do we.
In fact,
we accidentally ate some.
Wait.
What was this commercial about?
I don't know.
My memory's not so good
since I ate that asbestos.
So call us and tell us
what our names are.
We can't remember!"
[ Laughter ]
The fate of our democracy is
very much on the brink
and yet, so many
of our institutions,
from political parties
to media organizations,
are far too willing
to rehabilitate
the key perpetrators
of a slow-moving coup,
all for entertainment
or profit or political gain.
The rot in our political system
goes deep.
These guys are all...
-♪ Bad to the bone ♪
[ Laughter ]
Is our wah-wah horn broken?
This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over two million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS,
cancer, and other
serious illnesses
and they need your help,
now, more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the Donate button.
Stay safe. Get vaccinated.
We love you.